céline j'ai dit elle est analyste
spécialiste du yémen
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france ce matin alors la
brigade de géant cette ses combattants
composée de milices progouvernementales
ont annoncé hier se retirer d'un secteur
clef du conflit au yémen
quelle est la particularité de cette
unité de forces spéciales
de l'armée les manettes
vie bonjour en fait il à la brigade des
géants ou en fait c'est une brigade qui
a été composée aux finances et si on
appelait ça par les personnes qui
restait de l'armée yéménite mais qui
sont en même temps financer deux par les
émirats arabes par la commission mais
particulièrement par les inénarrables
sont assez proches de la brigade si on
peut appeler ça une brigade qui est
gérée par le le neveu de l'ancien
président aimé ni tata il ya le fauteuil
da et c'est une brigade qui est vu par
la coalition ou et où on essaie de
véhiculer djibri 4 qui essayait de
défendre
le gouvernement ait lieu et aussi les
intérêts les vrais intérêts des
yéménites toutefois c'est une brigade
qui aussi et des rumeurs ou les
remarques qui ont été faites à cette
date c'est qu'elle a ramassé si je fais
appeler ça comme ça où elle est
constituée d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui participaient faisaient
partie des groupes qui étaient des
groupes assez j'irai pas al-qaïda mais
des goûts des troupes qui était qui
faisait partie des mille ici je peux
appeler ça comme ça mais pour le moment
c'est une c'est une brigade qui essaie
de se montrer comme une brigade qui
défend les intérêts de du gouvernement
et de la coalition cette brigade a s'est
retirée donc un secteur clé du conflit
au yémen qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur
ce secteur clé justement ce retrait
pourquoi son retrait est est ce que
c'est une victoire pour les rebelles
houthi
en fait quelque chose à préciser c'est
que on essaie de véhiculer une image de
marennes comme une région clé qui est
très riche en
très riche qui a beaucoup de ressources
naturelles entreprises effectivement
l'intérêt de cette région c'est de la
géographie si je peux appeler ça c'est
la géographie naturel c'est une région
qui est assez qui n'est pas très loin de
des frontières d'un côté avec l'arabie
saoudite et un autre côté effectivement
et des ressources naturelles mais pas
autant que que que les informations à
deux du gouvernement ministre de la
coalition a essayé de montrer mais en
fait ça reste une histoire de rivalités
de pouvoir sur un terrain et
et cette option et c'est la dernière
région on peut dire la plus grosse
région où le gouvernement yéménite avec
la coalition essayer de maintenir un
certain niveau de présence c'est un
passage aussi qui obligatoire pour tous
ceux qui souhaitent quitter lui-même
pour partir à l'étranger pour se faire
soigner quand ils le peuvent c'est un
passage aussi important pour tout ce qui
est est d' humanitaires ou par rapport à
la nourriture donc c'est une région qui
est intéressant toutefois on ne peut pas
ignorer uni et que c'est une région qui
est riche mais c'est toutes les
ressources naturelles sont compliqués à
assortir ouen l'exploitation des
ressources reste quand même être très
compliqué pour le moment aujourd'hui
c'est une carte qui a été jouée par le
gouvernement yéménite mais les outils la
voit comme une région comme à entraver
sa un sésame et le fait d'avoir cette
région et dre non seulement d'avoir la
mamie sur les aides qui arrivent mais
aussi sur le gaz sur les ressources
naturelles qui s'y trouve est aussi
contrôler tout le transfert ou le le
transfert est les déplacements aussi le
transit entre le yémen du nord et aussi
lui-même du sud voir l'arabie saoudite
donc ça signifie quoi sur la
position des rebelles houthi maintenant
dans sa toge région le retrait de cette
brigade bah ça veut dire les outils en
fait c'est une région qui est disputé
depuis plusieurs années des pieds la
coalition qui intervient au yémen c'est
à dire depuis 2015 et cette région elle
a été prise reprise mais ç'a toujours
resté pendant cinq six ans sous le
contrôle du gouvernement et de la
coalition maintenant qu'elle soit prise
par le par les outils cela veut dire que
le le gouvernement yéménite où les
représentants de l'aide de la coalition
ils vont être et tous les non seulement
par rapport au passage où la liberté de
circuler
de de sanaa jusqu'à cette région jusqu'à
l'aéroport aussi d'adel mais aussi déjà
les outils sans soupçonner mais en fait
soupçonnées m'a pas tort de 2,2
intervenir au de d'un t2 d'empêcher les
aides humanitaires ce soit au niveau des
médicaments ou de la nourriture et là ça
va être encore une fois une vraie
en fait si je peux appeler ça ils vont
être complètement être anglais dans
cette zone et ça va faciliter aussi la
possibilité d outils d'intervenir ou de
menaces et l'arabie saoudite mais aussi
de s'approcher de chute vers le soin
d'elle mais aussi al qaeda parce que
cette région reste quand même levé au
bout si je peux appeler ça comme ça par
rapport à ces régions là merci beaucoup
à vous c'est les mêmes choisi d'avoir
répondu en directeur à nos questions sur
arte france rappelle que vous êtes
analyste spécialiste du yémen